like hamzat tweeted out was like oh I'll  fight at 85 I'll be your champ now if  the UFC actually want Hamza to be that  big of a superstar at 70 and 85 your  next fight to me harms up Versace Pierre  Hamza beats the [ __ ] out he mops the  floor you know again I'm not taking  anything from Alex this is all about  matchups and styles and that's a  complete nightmare for him the UFC is  not going to do that because then it  discredits  is he's kind of entire resume right  because then  if Izzy never gets that  fourth fight really the the second fight  MMA which all we care about but if he  never gets that rematch against Alex and  then Alex fights anybody else and loses  and never gets because they have to have  him fight Izzy otherwise you'll never  hear him from him again I gotta be  honest so the UFC knows that and it'd  also be a huge kind of  Mark against Izzy in his career if he  couldn't redeem himself and get a win  over Alex